hallo leute in diesem video geht es
wieder um deutsche werben
wir stellen euch heute das werk machen
vor wir zeigen euch wie es in
verschiedenen zeitformen bilden und
benutzen könnt dazu geben wir euch
natürlich auch viele beispiele
los geht's im präsens also der gegenwart
ich mache
du machst er sie es macht wir machen
ihr macht wie machen die strafen waren
macht viel lärm
ihr macht einen kurs an der sprachschule
ich mache mich hübsch
jetzt mache ich ein foto von mir das
lange warten macht mich wahnsinnig ich
machte
du machst ist er sie es machte mir
machte ihr machte sie machten
janosch machte sich gedanken
alina machte sich einen schönen tag
alina machte iranisch ein kompliment
janosch machte sich sorgen
[Musik]
ich habe gemacht du hast gemacht er sie
es hat gemacht wir haben gemacht
ihr habt gemacht sie haben gemacht
[Musik]
ich habe ein klinge streich gemacht
ich habe einen fehler gemacht alina hat
einen großen sprung gemacht
alina hat große augen gemacht
[Musik]
janisch hat sauber gemacht
ich werde machen du wirst machen er sie
es wird machen wir werden machen
ihr werdet machen sie werden machen wo
gott ich glaube ich habe das mikro
kaputtgemacht janosch wird mir eine
ansage machen was ist denn das schon
wieder
ich glaube der tonus weg zweimal
ich glaube es ist alles in ordnung der
ton ist da ja ok
soll ich mich heute laufen ja das werde
ich machen
janosch wird einen spaziergang machen
[Musik]
alina wir werden jetzt ein video machen
was genau machen wir also du wirst einen
großen sprung machen aber dann werden
sich die leute lustig über mich machen
alina das ist genau das was wir wollen
janosch ich glaube ich werde jetzt eine
pause machen
[Musik]
ich würde machen
du würdest machen er sie es würde machen
wir würden machen
ihr würdet machen sie würden machen
ich würde das nicht so machen
um euch zum lachen zu bringen würde ich
mich sogar zum affen machen
das würde mir spaß machen
das würde mich auch glücklich machen
vielleicht würde mich das sogar reich
machen wenn ihr noch mehr deutsche
werben lernen wollt dann probiert doch
mal den vokabeltrainer in unserer app
siedlung aus dort findet er die
wichtigsten 6000 deutschen werben
zusammen mit beispiel setzen und
aussprache training dann bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]